what would you say is your filmmaking
style
i think the kind of films that i love to
watch
and therefore are the films that kind of
i seek to make
are kind of you know very very indie
very raw
very rugged kind of you know rough
around the edges
but films that have their heart in the
right place
i think definitely that's the kind of
filmmaking that i gravitate
towards and filmmakers who take risks
like big risks are the ones that you
know i
i look up to and want to emulate so even
growing up you you weren't maybe drawn
as much toward the blockbusters
as as some of these i would do the same
thing i would look for these raw
gritty like indie films that you
sometimes even saw the boom mic hanging
down
just because the story there was
something
because that's the thing it's like i
think that the
you know again i guess just to go back
to kids because
i mentioned it before it's like there
are i
distinctly remember like a section in
kids where it's
the two the two male protagonists
they're talking on a subway train
and one of them like blocks the other
and technically speaking that would be
wrong like oh no no we next this camera
angle but the camera just like
sits there and it waits for him to just
lean back
and it's things like that that it's it's
you feel that it's not really about
what's right in a film or what's
technically correct it's about the story
and that's always
the thing that is going to make you keep
coming back to a film is the story
because it's so good it's so engaging
and i mean come on let's face it i mean
there are quite a few blockbusters that
you watch and you think
how on earth did this script get
greenlit
like how how much love went into this
script
i'm not i'm i'm wondering how much love
went into it whereas like you watch a
film like
like fish tank again because andre
arnold is one of my
of my absolute favorites or moonlight
how how much passion went into that
script you know that it did it's you you
can't question it it's it's there
to to see to feel um
and and that's sometimes my issue with
big blockbuster films is i wonder just
how much heart
is really in them and also it feels like
with a lot of indie films they're the
the writer directors are okay with
having
a question at the end where it's not in
a pretty box
and i think there's something nice about
that because that's what life is i mean
yeah we don't know i mean to say
something very dark and very greek
the only pretty box you can expect at
the end of life is the coffin right
let's face it very true yeah right
right okay that makes sense but but yeah
i mean and
i think that is the problem that either
people have against indie films or
or for them is that the ending isn't
always
you know um there's a question at the
end and i like that
you know i'd rather have a question
rather than know exactly
how does instinct factor into filmmaking
i think especially for a director it's
really
crucial really critical because i think
you know sometimes on on set you have to
be able to look at a performance
and know is this is this going to work
is it not going to work because i think
i think
sometimes you're not really sure if
anything's going to work 100
so all you've got is your gut and i
think especially
you know i like when i'm asked oh you
know what would you tell like young
filmmakers i always say that you've got
to trust your instincts
because even if you get it wrong it
doesn't matter you'll make a better
film next time around and you learn so
much more from failure than you do from
success so just don't be afraid and
don't make any excuses
and did that instinct go into casting
for your first feature
for sure and i think especially i mean i
i
want to say especially with non-actors
you have to be able to see something in
them that maybe they don't necessarily
see
themselves right and how was that for
you to try
not not maybe convince but but
encourage and some of these actors that
maybe they weren't i don't know were
they
did they take dramatic arts or or you
saw something in them and just knew it
and then showing that in them i mean i
think that most of them were
were really beginners first-timers
um i'm not too sure if they had done any
like
little sketches in class or anything
like that
i can't speak to that but i think that
in terms of like
being on camera they didn't really have
any experience at all
but you know i mean i was reading i was
reading an interview the other day
that sofia lauren gave
and she was saying that you know even in
all her years as a professional actress
and as a start
the thing that she wants most of all
from a director
is trust and kind of you know
i think she was saying this about um
vittorio de sika that
he had more faith than me than i had in
myself
and that was so important to me as an
actress
so i think that's what you know it when
you make your casting choices if you
really believe in an
either in an actor or an actress that's
what you got to make them feel is that
i trust you a hundred percent i've got
you
you can do this so let's go yeah